just being introduced up in Chapman Hall
we'll bring you this to you live and a
reminder that this whole program
everything you've seen today will re-air
tonight at midnight Eastern Time and
we'll be back again live tomorrow
foundation OHL oriano
american airlines and many other
generous sponsors we also like to
acknowledge the Friends of the books
there and we see many of them here today
please join me in thanking them for
their generosity towards the end of the
session we will have a Q&A opportunity
with a microphone in the center of the
aisle the authors will also be
autographing books in the area near
where you lined up prior to entering
towards the right of the elevator at
this time I invite you to please silence
your cell phones and of course enjoy the
program I'd like to introduce dr.
Eldridge Birmingham who's the chief
science officer of the frost museum
Alliance he will introduce our authors
it's great to be here I even get a book
in autograph so I'm feeling very lucky a
very young-looking Richard Dawkins here
so as you were told I'm elders herb if
Birmingham I'm the chief science officer
this magnificent museum that's being
built around the corner on that dynamic
edge between the other glades and the
Gulf Stream and sitting between the
temperate zone in the tropics own we
invite you all to come it'll open in
about a year but that's not the point
tonight I'm here to introduce Richard
Dawkins and first I have to tell you
just a very quick tale I was a student
at Cornell University in the 70s when
Selfish Gene came out and I was on my
way and actually started in veterinary
college at Cornell University and I
became so enthralled with the book and
with the conversation that ensued at
Cornell around the book that I changed
my own career direction went into
genetics I owe a lot to to Richard
Dawkins so Richard Dawkins has been
voted Prospect magazine's number one
world thinker quite an honor has
previously published 11 books all still
in print including The Selfish Gene the
blockbuster besto The God Delusion and
obviously as magnum opus the ancestors
tale this is actually really remarkable
when you think about it Richard's a
fellow of both the Royal Society
and the Royal Society of literature he
was the inaugural holder of the summin
summin a chair for public understanding
of science at Oxford University and is
the recipient of numerous honorary
degrees and awards including the
international cosmos prize of Japan
which I actually think is more
incredible than the Nobel Prize for
those of you who know about the cosmos
prize in an appetite for wonder the
making of a scientist Richard Dawkins
shows a rare view into his early life
his intellectual awakening at Oxford and
is paths to writing The Selfish Gene
here for the first time is an intimate
memoir of the childhood in intellectual
development of the evolutionary
biologist and world-famous atheist and
the story of how he came to write what
is widely held to be one of the most
important books of the 20th century
doctor professor Dawkins is also going
to be joined on stage by Geoffrey Alan
Lieberman
holds the I've got to look at this the
Liebherr chair and directs the Liebherr
Center for schizophrenia research in the
department of psychiatry at Columbia and
serves the psychiatrist in chief of New
York Presbyterian Hospital Columbia
University Medical Center I'll leave it
to all of you in to dr. Lieberman to
explain why we have somebody who studies
schizophrenia interviewing Professor
Richard Dawkins
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you very much Eldridge I'm
Jeffrey Lieberman in case you didn't
recognize or couldn't distinguish who
was who and this is Professor Richard
Dawkins Eldridge thank you for that I
will answer why a psychiatrist if any
schizophrenia is interviewing a scholar
who has focused in terms of one of his
works on the evolutionary significance
of genes but basically it's all genetics
as professor Dawkins has told us before
we begin I just want to say how pleased
I am to be here and to offer my
gratitude to Mitchell Kaplan who's been
the inspiration and co-founder of the
Miami Book Fair and also to a professor
padrone who is the president of
miami-dade College for hosting this
event it's truly a magnificent event and
something for the city of Miami to be
proud of um Eldridge introduced
Professor Dawkins which I could add to
but won't in the interest of saving time
we're going to talk for roughly a half
an hour and then open the floor for a
few minutes of questions so ready
yourself if you're like inclined ask a
question the reason we're here tonight
is because professor Dawkins in addition
to his academic and scientific research
has been inclined to speak to the public
and educate the public about scientific
issues but also about non scientific
issues from the perspective of a
scientist and that's something that's
not easy to do and not many of his
scientific colleagues are inclined to do
Alan Alda things actor who's a good
friend of mine is an admiration of
scientists who do this and said not
enough do it or are able to do it so I
want to first thank professor Dawkins
for his prodigious output and really
putting himself into the sort of battle
field of the public arena by trying to
speak and communicate scientific complex
issues to the public or even
non-scientific ways issues in a way that
involves sort of rigor
scientific analysis now professor
Dawkins has written 12 books now the
reason we're here tonight is because of
this one his memoir which is an appetite
for wonder the making of a scientist and
this is a departure from what he's done
before in this prior 11 books beginning
with The Selfish Gene and I guess I
would sort of start by asking this is a
memoir in reading it I was once a
surprise but sort of pleasantly sort of
to find that this is truly a memoir of
actually what your life was like from at
least your ancestry and birth up until
publication of The Selfish Gene and
immediately thereafter and I noticed
that one of the endorsements that you
had in the book was from The Guardian
where they said quote a surprisingly
intimate and moving book so why now why
after having written scientifically for
your for the academia and for the public
in the way that you have why was it time
to write a memoir I suppose it's time to
write a memoir because I'm still alive
and the motive the points actually my
mother is still alive at the age of 98
and so she where she has an excellent
memory and so I was able to tap her
memory for my childhood and indeed the
book includes a few extracts from her
Diaries so why does anyone write a
memoir I mean it's a it's a sort of
rather presumptuous thing to suppose
that anybody would want to read who will
not want to read a memoir about me oh is
it if you see what I mean and one of the
more hostile reviews that I got in an
English paper says something like the
trouble with this autobiography just
seems to be all about the author
so if I don't know really why now I
vaguely had it in mind that it might be
a good idea but I suppose the honest
answer is that the publishers wanted it
and and we're certainly glad they
invited you to do this so um I confess
to having certainly been familiar with
you and your work and particularly from
having read The Selfish Gene but in
reading this book I became aware of what
truly is an amazing life you've had I
mean you have had an extraordinary range
of experiences and family and colleagues
to to sort of contribute and to interact
with over the course of your life your
ancestry which is depicted pedigree in
the initial pages of the book is quite
fascinating your ethnic racial origins
are from England but you were born in
Kenya you then moved to South Africa you
then returned to England where you for
the most part remained except for a
stint in Berkeley and you had
educational experiences beginning in
Rhodesia at Eagle and then Chaffin Grove
in England and then oundle and then
another public school in England and
then on to Oxford and Balliol College UC
Berkeley and back to Oxford it seems
that it really was an amazing life which
in some way had to have contributed to
who you became and what you've been able
to do was it really that good or did you
leave anything out what's very nice to
have an interviewer who's obviously read
the book yes I wouldn't say that but
actually my childhood foreshadowed very
much my becoming a scientist I sort of
I was a bit of a late developer and it
wasn't until I got to Oxford as an
undergraduate that I really became
obsessed with science and even then it
wasn't the Natural History aspects of
science that intrigued me but rather the
philosophical ones I was intrigued by
the deep questions of existence what why
is there life at all what's it all about
what's it for and I early decided that
biology evolution especially was the the
right way to answer that kind of
question so I didn't know whether my
life stats fascinating doesn't everybody
have an interesting life I I suppose I
was born in Africa which not everybody
was though our species was by the way
and so in a way I was I went back to not
just my roots but everybody's roots my
foundation the Richard Dawkins
foundation for reason and science has a
t-shirt which says we are all Africans
and it means that early all he was we're
all a brotherhood of sisterhood we're
all close relatives and we all hail from
the dark continent of Africa you moved
your family moved to England when you
were eight but prior to that you were in
South Africa and you went to the Eagle
School in Rhodesia now Zimbabwe even at
that young age did you have some
particular sort of experience or
recollections given the political
circumstances in apartheid
no not really it was actually a
Nyasaland which was a British colony
which is just a little bit north of
South Africa so that no but although
there was no apartheid there was the
typical British imperial racism in the
sense of a kind of patronizing
condescension to the Africans we lived a
life of sort of Edwardian or almost
Victorian Gentry with servant
and the the men were called boys so it
was a patronizing they were kind of
manure
badly but they were treated with
condescension as though they were
children which is in a way of more
incident a more insidious kind of racism
I suppose you could say and I'm sure
this was true of the whole British
Empire probably the French Empire as the
Dutch Empire and things as well
and and that really didn't didn't change
until though I probably the 1950s but
your first seminal publication for the
public The Selfish Gene introduced a new
sort of thesis to extend our
understanding of the mechanism of
evolution and that is through genetics
and in this genes are the currency of
evolution and and play a role as the
medium or the the mechanistic medium by
which selective pressures natural
selection is brought to bear on an
evolution so in some ways which you
wrote this in 1976 yes it was really
prescient because as a physician who
studies human disease in the wake of the
sequencing of the genome which occurred
in 2003 our whole understanding of the
role of genetics the way diverse way in
which the genes and DNA chromosomes can
express themselves has totally
transformed our opinion about how we
understand illness how we understand
sort of human biology and life and you
had anticipated this in the context of
your evolutionary biological career
which is quite extraordinary I'm not
sure if that's yet been fully
appreciated how you had sort of foreseen
this but in order to become a little
more entertaining for the audience let
me try and come back to the
autobiographical stuff and get a little
personal you your father was a botanist
your mother was a naturalist and some of
the orientation you've been married
three times yes you're currently married
you have one daughter yes the thesis of
The Selfish Gene is that way evolution
works is that genes are inclined to
perpetuate themselves through
procreation yes I think the point here
is that we see animals and plants as
bodies as great big things which which
walk around and do things and grow and
fit and so on but what's really going on
is information digital information is
just like computer information which in
our kind of life is DNA and it's only
DNA that actually survives when you talk
about the survival of the fittest when
you talk about the struggle for
existence bodies do struggle for
existence but they don't struggle for
perpetual existence they struggle only
to reproduce they struggle to survive
and they struggle to reproduce and that
means they struggle to pass on the
digital information that built them in
the first place the genes that are now
inside us potentially can go on for
millions of years in the form of exact
copies of themselves with occasional
inexactitude which is which is mutation
and the cause genes are potentially
immortal because they're in the
information form they're potentially
immortal that means that the ones that
are successful in surviving go on
forever or for a very very long long
time as forever compared to ordinary
generation time successful genes go on
through future generations unsuccessful
ones don't bodies are just the temporary
throwaway survival machines for the
genes that built them and that write
inside them and because they write
inside them the death of the body is the
death of the gene the failure of the
body to reproduce
is the failure of the genes to get
through into the next generation so what
we see as we look around the world is
bodies that were made by successful
genes and by successful I mean very
strictly successful at making ancestors
another way to look at it is that every
living creature is descended from an
unbroken line of successful ancestors
every single one of your ancestors
succeeded in achieving at least one
heterosexual copulation and that's not
true of the great majority of animals
that have ever lived most most animals
that have ever lived have either died
young or failed to get a mate so we are
all descended from an elite of organisms
that have back to the beginning of life
and an elite lineage that has succeeded
in every single generation in surviving
long enough to reproduce and then and
then reproducing so we all of us whether
we're humans or bats or or wombats or
hippopotamuses or pine trees we we all
of us carry the genes that make us good
at what we do and what we do in the case
of bats is flying the case of dolphins
is swimming in the case of mold is
diggin in the case of given zips wings
but by their arms through the treetops
and in the case of humans is thinking so
all different species do it a different
way but fundamentally they're ordering
exactly the same thing which is working
to preserve the genetic instructions
that made them in the first place and
the drive inside them as the vehicle
that they ride inside and their fate is
bound up in the fate of the vehicle that
that they built so they better be good
at building vehicles better be good at
building bodies or they wouldn't be here
and they are here or we wouldn't see
them so all the animals that we
we are good at doing what they do or
potentially good at doing what what they
do because they are descended from an
unbroken line of successful ancestors
and inherit the genes that made them
successful so genes are the replicators
and bodies whether they be animals or
humans or plants are the vehicles why
didn't you have more children well I am
NOT a believer in the idea that because
natural selection genetic selection is
what gives us existence that that should
dictate what we ought to do it's
perfectly true that we are programmed
like all animals and all plants to spend
all our time and all our energy in
struggling to reproduce but the great
glory of the human species is that we
have through the process of evolution by
natural selection acquired brains that
are big enough to emancipate themselves
from the struggles that gave rise to
them in the first place
Steven Pinker the grapes linguist and
psychologist put it well when he said I
do not intend to reproduce and if my
selfish genes don't like it they can go
jump in the lake if this is actually
quite a serious point - two points I'd
make one is a kind of political point
that if we really did or govern our
lives by a selfish gene point of earthly
rate if we really did in our daily lives
fulfill the aims of our selfish genes we
would be living in a very very
unpleasant society we'd be living in a
dog-eat-dog society a sort of
Thatcherite Reaganite
he carried to an extreme we would be
indulging in rape and pillage and and
sort of things that Vikings were
historically reputed to do or Genghis
Khan and and we've we've got beyond that
in one respect we haven't got beyond it
because one of the things that was built
into our gene into our into our brains
by genetic selection was a tendency for
brains to set up goals and purposes
which originally would have had the
purpose or goal of propagating genes so
originally we were equipped in our
brains with the tendency to set up
purposes like fine food find a cave to
live in find a waterhole take care to
avoid being eaten by a lion all aimed
towards the ultimate goal of
reproduction but because we were given
in our brains for software to set our
goals and sub goals and sub sub goals we
can use those at software that goal
seeking software to set up other girls
have actually have nothing to do with
reproduction we can set up a goal to
write a book and satisfy the publishers
we can set up a goal to win a football
game we can set up a goal to well all
the different things that we do we most
of the time are setting up short-term
goals that we want to achieve little
knowing that the goal seeking software
that we're using was originally put
there by natural selection for the
ultimate goal of reproducing of having
lots of children but we've cut the
ground from under the feet of that and
we now set up these other girls which
our ancestors always did anyway but in
that case their sub goals were directed
towards the ultimate goal of
reproduction nowadays they're set up
they're directed towards other girls are
like as I say I'm reading a book or
finishing writing a book
the goal of reproduction in any case is
well served by the more proximate goal
of having sex which we still do whether
we want our selfish genes to go jump in
the lake or not and in our primitive
ancestors it would have been enough to
have a strong sex drive that would have
been children would tend to have a
follow automatically in the world
without contraception but nowadays in a
world with contraception we can all
enjoy ourselves and tell our genes to go
and jump in the lake now one of and
perhaps the most sort of innovative and
also controversial aspect of your
genetic thesis is the concept of the
extended phenotype and just reading from
The Selfish Gene the definition of the
extended phenotype is an animal's
behavior or or their appearance because
it's not limited to how they behave it's
also how they look and their size and so
forth tends to maximize the survival of
the genes for that behavior or physical
characteristic whether or not those
genes happen to be in the body of the
particular organism performing it may be
a little complicated yes okay when I
said that the fate of the genes is bound
up in the vehicle that they write about
in that is true most of the time but my
second book the extended phenotype which
was written mainly for professional
audience generalizes the principle and
points out that actually the phenotype
the phenotype is the external
manifestation of genetic tendencies and
mostly phenotypes are parts of the body
in which the genes ride so the the legs
of a bee
ever the tail of a beaver the eyes of a
beaver the whiskers of a beaver the fur
of a beaver these are all phenotypic
manifestations of genes inside the
beaver genes riding around inside the
vehicle that is the beaver and their
survival is served by the effects that
they have on the hair the tail the legs
the eyes the muzzle etc of the beaver
but of course beavers also do other
things well-known things like they build
dams and lodges and the dam of a beaver
is this was really my contribution the
dam of a beaver is part of its phenotype
because in exactly the same way as genes
survived because of their effects on the
body of the vehicle in which they ride
in special cases like beaver dams genes
survive by virtue of their effects on
the dam which is not part of the Beavers
body and is not something that they ride
inside but nevertheless is phenotypic
effect in the same way as the tail of
the beaver or the whiskers of the beaver
is phenotypic effect so any animal
artifact a bird's nest or spider's web a
beaver dam a termite mound these all can
be regarded as extended phenotypes that
was the first step in the argument of
the extended phenotype and then I
generalized it to say well in the same
way as the Beaver Dam or the caddis
house you know caddy slavi our cat
caddisflies a fairly nondescript for the
brown insects that fly about but their
larvae build for themselves little
houses out of stones or out of sticks or
out of little tiny snail shells and they
cement them together and they make a
beautiful little house in which the lava
lives so it's like a snail shell but
it's built by the behavioral efforts of
the lava it's a most remarkable process
to watch the the building of a caddis
lava house now
that the house in which the caddis lives
is an extended phenotype now compare
that to a snail a snail has a shell
which is secreted by the body of the
snail and is part of the normal
phenotype of the snail now consider a
parasite a fluke say living inside the
snail and the the fluke gains protection
from the snail shell just as the snail
gains protection from the snail shell
and just as the caddy Slava gains
protection from the stone house but the
fluke at least in some cases has an
influence on the snail shell snails that
have a fluke inside them at least in one
case that I've studied snails that have
a fluke inside them have thicker shells
than snails without a fluke it looks as
though the fluke is this kind of worm it
looks as though the fluke is improving
the snail shell for its own good
why would it do that why why if the
snail shell could be improved why
doesn't the snail do it anyway see what
I'm building towards that the snail
shell or the extra thickening of the
snail shell is part of the extended
phenotype of genes in the fluke natural
selection comes along and favors genes
in the fluke that have phenotypic pale
shell why doesn't flail do it anyway
because there's a compromise between the
needs of survival and reproduction a
snail that had a shell that was too
thick would be less likely to reproduce
because it puts too much work too much
energy into thickening its shell and
doesn't have enough left over for
reproduction so the optimum shell
thickness for the
flutes of a parasite inside the snail is
thicker than for the snail itself which
is why I'm saying that the thicker shell
is an extended phenotype of the fluke
generalizing that again anytime that a
parasite has an affect on its host which
many of them do sometimes quite
remarkable effects we can call that an
extended phenotype there's another kind
of worm called a brain worm which
infects ants and an infected aunt
it has its behavior change the brain
room actually burrows into the brain of
the ant and makes a lesion in the brain
of the ant just like a physiologist
might make a lesion in the brain of the
ant and causes the ant to instead of
going down into the ground in the heat
of the day the ant goes up stems grass
stems to the top where it shouldn't be
in the middle of the day and there it
becomes vulnerable to being eaten by a
sheep which is exactly what the brain
worm wants because the brain worms next
host after the
after the sleep the ant is a sheep
there are lots and lots of examples of
parasites manipulating their hosts for
their own advantage and now I want to
regard every one of those changes in the
host behavior as an extended phenotype
finally the parasite doesn't actually
have to live inside its host cuckoos and
covers which are sort of American
equivalent of cuckoos parasitized other
birds by laying eggs in the other bird's
nest and then the cuckoo hatches out and
I talked about cuckoo is not not
cowbirds European cookers and all kinds
of adaptations is the of the the nesting
cuckoo influence the host cause the host
to the hosts bird to to rare it to feed
it you see grotesque pictures of
gigantic baby cuckoos
dwarf in their foster parent and the
foster parent is frantically working to
stuff food into the gaping maw of the of
the cuckoo the cook who somehow manages
to exert an influence on the behavior of
the host fat again is an extended
phenotype even though the cuckoo doesn't
live inside its host and then you can
generalize that to any influence that
animals have on each other the
nightingales song proverbially
intoxicating my heart aches and a drowsy
numbness pains my sense of Hemlock I had
drunk one minute past and leafy woods
had sunk keith was not a bird he was a
he was a mammal but the effect that the
drugging effect as though of hemlock I
had drunk the drugging effect on John
Keats is I'm conjecturing the same as
the male Nightingale is having on a
female Nightingale so the the female
Nightingale is being drugged by that by
the male Nightingale song manipulated
it's as though a brain physiologist had
come along and injected a drug into the
into the female the male can't do that
he doesn't have a hypodermic but he does
have have a voice and the voice has been
honed over generations to become an
extremely powerful intoxicating
influence so intoxicating that it even
intoxicated John Keats who's who dude at
whom it was not aimed since he is not a
female Nightingale okay that's enough on
the extended phenotype sorry went on a
bit long
[Applause]
now as you know better than any of us
there have been a number of sir
questions and challenges and criticisms
of the kind of evolutionary biological
thesis of the role of genetic mechanisms
including the extended phenotype just to
sort of ask you to try and comment
refute a couple of the most obvious what
is altruism how do you explain altruism
and you invoke or you describe your
belief in the Hamilton rule bill
Hamilton or William Hann with a
colleague of yours a friend and I'll
allow you to explain that to the
audience and then does that apply to one
of your Oxford mentors Mike Cullen who
had such a significant influence in your
career yes the the book The Selfish Gene
could just as well have been called the
altruistic gene because it much of the
book is actually about altruism it's
widely misunderstood as being a book
about selfishness or even an advocacy of
selfishness it's thought to be that by
people who've read the book by title
only reading the title and omitting the
rather large footnote which is the book
itself it's a lot of it is about
altruism and it discusses two main ways
in which altruistic organisms are
favored by selfish genes selfish genes
because they are the Immortals because
they're the ones that go through the
generations they achieve this feat of
going through the generations partly by
programming their bodies their vehicles
into being very good at surviving at the
expense of others that would be being
selfish partly by programming them to
reproduce obviously can't get into the
next generation if you're a gene if you
don't cause your vehicle to reproduce
but also there is another way to do it
with with collateral kin you can
calculate and and it's been done
and you can calculate the probability
that's a gene in you will be in any
relative you like like a nephew a niece
a sister a great nephew a grandchild and
the probability is and is a known
function is easy to cut easy to
calculate so if you imagine a gene for
making an individual be altruistic
towards say nieces that gene has a 25%
chance of ending up in the body of the
niece helped so therefore if the cost of
the altruist if the cost to the altruist
is not very great and the benefit to the
niece to the beneficiary is great and in
this case since of the 25% it has to be
four times as great then that gene will
survive there will be a tendency for
that gene to survive Bill Hamilton who
knew just mentioned my colleague and
friend was the one who worked out this
theory worked it out very thoroughly in
in 1964 he himself was a great expert in
social insects and which of course are
the supreme altruists who look after kin
other than their own offspring most of
the work in an ant colony or a termite
colony or Ibiza or beehive is done by
workers who are sterile who have no
prospect of reproducing themselves but
instead put all their efforts into the
reproduction of the queen or males and
in the rearing of young Queens and young
males who maybe their younger siblings
or their nephews and nieces so the
social insects are the sort of showcase
of this theory of kin selection and
although they're the showcase the theory
applies to all animals even if they
don't actually show altruism towards
collateral kin towards nephews and
nieces or brothers and sisters
the reason they don't show it is that
the economics of the situation don't
favor it
you'll only get an actual evolution of
sibling altruism or nice altruism
if the economic circumstances favour it
taking into account this probability
factor of the probability of sharing a
gene it happens that the ecological
economic circumstances of ants bees
wasps and termites are such as to favor
extreme kin altruism and there are a
part of a number of other animals which
are a little bit less extreme quite a
lot of birds like acorn woodpeckers in
California quite a lot of mammals in
most extreme being the naked mole-rat of
east africa which are kind of vertebrate
equivalents of social insects it's a
powerful theory and and a correct one so
Eldridge shows where the schizophrenia
comes in so then how do you understand
conditions diseases such as autism or
schizophrenia which in which the
reproductive capacity of individuals is
significantly impaired but their
population frequency remains stable or
even increases if you believe the CDC
figures of rates of autism United States
that the the question of why we have any
genetic diseases at all of course is
easily answered by my mutation that
there's a certain rare occurrence of
mutations which are disadvantageous and
things like hemophilia Huntington's
chorea these these terrible afflictions
which are which are genetic
verax plane bind by mutation mutation
happens mutation has to happen or
evolution natural selection would have
nothing to work on there accidental
there just is mistakes and we notice the
ones that are bad as many of them are
but when you talk about things like
schizophrenia which occur and which
occur at a higher frequency than you'd
expect
by nutation that's a real puzzle and it
one is kind of tempted to think along
the lines of could there be some sort of
advantage in I mean I probably it's hard
to imagine it for schizophrenia but one
could imagine in some cases that perhaps
autism that autistic individuals might
have advantages under some circumstances
it doesn't sound all that plausible but
but it's it has been suggested that
perhaps there the extreme of a spectrum
and maybe milder forms along the
spectrum have an advantage but this is
your field more than mine so I oughtn't
to be to be really pontificating about
it well maybe if I write a book someday
I'll interview me about this so I can't
as you know conclude the interview
without asking you at least one question
about the guide delusion which was one
of your books somewhat of a departure so
how is your and I gather you were
acquainted if not friends with
Christopher Hitchens and you spoke at
his funeral so how does your view of
religion in this context sort of compare
to those of Hitchens or Sam Harris in
this country who's written about this
well but they're pretty similar
I mean Christopher Hitchens his book is
his God is not great sam harris wrote
the end of faith and letter to a
christian nation those are the two books
which which are about about atheism for
him i would say that my approach to
atheism is the sort of more scientific
one I'm interested in the academic
question of whether there is a supreme
intelligence creative intelligence
behind the universe which I regard as a
scientific question it would be a very
interesting scientific hypothesis that
there is a creative intelligence behind
the universe a universe with a creative
intelligence would be a very different
kind of universe from one without so I
think it's a scientific question and
that for me is primary
the book also includes moral value
considerations as well I think for
Christopher it's rather that the values
and the Mott and the morality and the
politics come first he regarded God I
mean I suppose especially the
judeo-christian Muslim God as as a
tyrant as it as a dictator a sort of in
a sort of surest celestial North Korea
and again he said the difference is that
in in North Korea you can at least
escape by dying fair enough I wanted to
sort of share an ad related to religion
as a matter of fact an anecdote that
relates to the issue of how your book
has impacted individuals people our
society and I'm not sure to what degree
you've sort of informed yourself about
that or what your thoughts are but just
by coincidence on the way down here
today I was talking with a friend who's
actually in the audience
Marc Jackman say a young man recently
graduated from college who's a
journalist now for one of the television
networks and he read The Selfish Gene
when he was a freshman and he was in a
parochial school and it said completely
transformed his thinking about this and
all of a sudden what might have been
viewed as sort of like the delusion or
the fabrication that is sort of
presented to people in a kind of
religion or in parochial school you know
had a different in a different view as
if the curtain had been pulled back and
he had a much more enlightened sort of
understanding event and he related
something I just can't help but mention
was that his mother came in to talk to
many one
and said I love you and she said of
course you do I have your jeans up so he
didn't he didn't go off the rails and
end up doing anything that was a
disruptor but do you have in the context
of how your book has impacted society do
you have any any distinct or vivid
impressions well I must say it's true
that a lot of people have said that it
changed them a lot of people have said
they went into biology because of it
which of course is immensely gratifying
to me I think it's probably true
that I hasten to say that the ideas in
The Selfish Gene are all in the
literature already I express them but
there they come from Fisher from halt
dein from Hamilton who me just mentioned
but I think it probably is as a result
of a selfish gene that biologists field
biologists doing muddy boots research in
the woods and fields and Serengeti and
Africa in places when they look at their
animals when they look at whatever their
animals are liens or seagulls or
whatever they are they are not they now
see those animals as maximizing their
own genetic survival and I think that
probably is a genuine change that's
that's come about so although I was in a
sense re expressing orthodoxy
neo-darwinian orthodoxy dating really
from the 1930s
I suppose I did put it in a sort of
vivid rhetorical language which caused
it to catch fire in them in the minds of
field biologists in the way that
previously had been rather sort of
academic and they perhaps haven't really
taken his on board I think that that's
the most credit I can I can claim so
we're going to stop in a moment and
invite questions for a few minutes but
before doing so I wanted to ask appetite
for wonder your current book takes us
through 1976
which is the year of the publication of
The Selfish Gene which is roughly half
of your life I'm what what comes next
and will you do a replay omit the
autobiography commissioned by the
publishers was supposed to be my whole
life when I got halfway through I sort
of felt the need for a sense of
accomplishment and so I asked the
publishers whether they would mind if
splitting it in half and they were
actually quite pleased about the idea so
I and they suggested that the Selfish
Gene would be a good break point and
indeed it was and so I stopped it at the
age of 35 and then the second volume is
one is I just about kind of finished it
now
it's called brief candle in the dark
which you'll instantly recognize as an
allusion to Shakespeare followed by Carl
Sagan out out brief candle and then
science as a candle in the dark and it
takes me up to my to my present age it
is not chronological in the way that
Volume one is an appetite for wonder it
is the magic and it that the themes are
things like television lectures books
that kind of thing and it will come out
in 2015 well I'm glad that I asked that
question we have something to look
forward to so I want to thank a
professor for this discussion and we
have a cue that's already forming we'll
take as many as the stage manager will
allow us so sir okay well my question is
this one of your fellow atheists Sam
Harris has just come out with a book
where he's you know focused on on
marrying you know rationality with
spirituality I'm kind of interested in
you know your atheistic perspective on
that and any thoughts on the
Ben Affleck Bill Maher Islam controversy
it would be to malign Sam Harris to
accuse him of becoming religious he's a
staunch an atheist as anyone he is a
great believer in meditation techniques
as a borders of the physiological
technique for leading a good life
meditation and meditation techniques
have been perfected by Buddhists and so
to that extent some could be confused
with a Buddhist but that should not take
the form of supernatural beliefs and
things like like reincarnation there's
nothing new about means that Sam has
been interested in meditation I think
much of his much of his life spiritual
concerns well I think Carl Sagan who's I
just quoted società the candle in the
dark also would have had a different
kind of spiritual concern as do I we one
responds in a sort of poetic way which
could be called spiritual to the the
wonders of the universe and of and of
life the Ben Affleck whom I didn't know
but I understand he's Batman what was on
Bill Maher's show with sam harris and he
vigorously and rather vitriolic ly
attacked sam accusing him of racism
because sam has criticized islam and
that's a very easy thing to do but it's
a very silly superficial thing to do
because of course Islam is not a race
and it is an enormous ly widespread
misconception that anybody who
criticizes Islam is being religious I
would say that if you can convert to it
or apostatize out of it then it's not a
race
okay so it's nonsense to to criticize
people like Sam Harris and indeed me who
who go after the extremes that Islam can
can can deliver as as as racism and I
thought it with a rather disgraceful
exhibition of bigotry on Ben Affleck's
part and there's a kind of condescension
about it actually as well because the
horrific things that are done in the
Islamic world not of course by ultimate
Muslims very far from it
but the horrific things that are done to
gay people to women stoning women to
death for the crime of being raped
throwing acid in their face for the
crime of refusing to marry a cousin
refusing to let them drive cars refusing
to let them leave the house with unless
in the company of a male relative these
horrific things misogynistic things are
it's almost as though one saying we you
you you brown people we don't hold you
to the same standards of a non misogyny
as we hold ourselves now isn't that a
patronizing and condescending thing to
do to use a different standard to say we
don't we don't criticize you because
you're because misogyny is part of your
culture and that I think is what Ben
Affleck was doing among among other
things it was it was a disagreeable
episode I thought Sam handled it very
well I think it was quite unexpected I
don't think that Ben Affleck actually
read anything that Sam had written I
think he troubled it had been briefed by
somebody who said Sam Harris is a racist
Islamophobe go after him that would be I
said what I suspect probably is
publicist yes sir yes person to meet you
again mr. Dawkins Gibson Sylvester armed
just had a question for you after having
read Darwin and I've read almost
everything you've ever written that's
been published one of the questions
that's always seemed to seep through my
mind is you know when we talk about the
big Big Bang Theory we talk about
evolution one of the questions that I
always have mulling around in my mind is
when you think of the first unicellular
organism has the scientific community
figured out where that first cell
originated from no it hasn't and it's
one of the it's one of the big open
questions it's something that happened a
very long time ago but probably about
four billion years ago not long after
the earth came into existence about four
four-and-a-half million years ago we
know the kind of thing it had to be it
had to be the origin of the first
self-replicating information the first
gene although it would certainly not
have been DNA DNA would have almost
certainly come in later and usurped the
role of the original replicator so most
of the theorizing I would say perhaps
all the theorizing that's going on now
is looking for the chemical event some
kind of a lucky random chemical event
which gave rise to a molecule which was
self-replicating as I say it would not
have been DNA DNA can't do its job
without protein and protein can't do its
job without DNA so there's a catch-22
there it could have been RNA because RNA
is capable both of doing the job of
protein which is being a catalyst and
enzyme a sort of executive function in
the cell and an RNA also can do what DNA
does name is a replication function
although not so well as DNA so the
current sort of vogue theory is that the
original self-replicating molecule might
have been RNA and it did both jobs both
the enzyme job was lately taken over by
protein and the replication job that was
later taken over by
DNA and RNA remains as a very important
mediator between them and this excuse me
we need to move out there's so many
people behind you okay thanks for the
great thank you so much for your great
answer yes sir yes good evening I read
The Selfish Gene quite a while ago and I
remember particularly the discussion of
the evolution of altruism and you
touched on that tonight talking about
kin selection but I believe the other
mechanism was reciprocal altruism and I
wonder is that still considered
currently viable and then what struck me
at the time in thinking about how that
might work is that Mike as a byproduct
of that if you have a certain selection
pressure to identify cheaters and if you
identify cheaters do you also punish
cheaters so I wondered if that's a
possible can you know that make sense
and has that been examined in the ANA in
in the biological world punishment
systems and this sort of thing yes very
much so
there are these really two prongs in
explaining altruism one is kin selection
as you said and the other reciprocal
altruism which where the individuals
concerned don't have to be kin they
don't even have to be members of the
same species not even the same Kingdom
there's reciprocal altruism between
between flowers and bees beat bees
pollinating the flowers flowers feeding
the bees with aviation fuel which is
nectar so reciprocation it works because
in game theory terms we have a
nonzero-sum game both parties benefit
from the other one's presence it's when
it happens within our species it often
comes concerns doing good turns feeding
the other individual for example in the
expectation of being fed later a
beautiful example of this is the work of
Wilkinson on bats vampire bats which as
you know suck blood and Wilkinson worked
out there's a kind of blood donor scheme
in in these baths
they feed at night and they can they go
and Nora where the the feet are the
heels of things like cows and blood and
anyone and then they go back to their
cave by day at any one night a bat may
strike lucky in which case it gets a
surface of blood or it may strike
unlucky and get no blood at all and
Wilkinson showed that if it gets no
blood at all
it's in grave danger of dying these bats
need food every single day
whereas when they get a surplus they've
got more than that than they need so
it's a perfect situation for reciprocal
altruism and they do indeed feed each
other a bat that has a surplus of blood
will be solicited by a bat that struck
unlucky that night and is starving and
the the one with a surplus will give its
surplus will regurgitate its surplus to
the to the to the starving one so that's
reciprocal altruism it's part of the
theory that this should only work if the
bats know each other so that they can
identify potential cheetahs as you said
and identify those individual bats who
do good terms and what Wilkinson did was
to set up artificial combinations of
bats in the lab and some of his
artificial combinations of bats were
from the same cave and therefore knew
each other and others of his artificial
conglomerates of bats didn't know each
other
and sure enough it turned out that the
ones that knew each other
practiced reciprocal altruism practice
the blood donor scheme whereas the ones
that did not know each other
he didn't didn't do that so it's just
one particular example but the theory
would be that it's a very very common
phenomenon and things like guilt
cheating consciousness of debt it may be
very important in human human evolution
our
very ability to do to do arithmetic may
come from a tendency to to reckon up
deaths the beat that we owe to potential
to to am ultra altruists as you're
answering I was trying to think of how
you would apply that altruistic
behavioral principles to Wall Street he
has it is come yes sir is there before
and during the Emancipation Proclamation
we find question was rise as to the
biology of the Negro whether a Negro is
a homo sapien er features a simple Homo
erectus another question that came about
the [ __ ] whether or not he can think
systematically in a scientific way today
we label schizophrenia as a Negro
disease ira black men disease sometimes
if you're researchers or so basis the
distich s-- my question is would the
rise of all these eugenics programs in
research that are being pounded that if
any ethnic group here faces challenges
like the new group faced in the past
right there I don't think I really
understand that I didn't really get work
I whether he are the result of these
eugenics but we're huge n is that
eugenics beta status in genetics
genetics genetics research generous
research which determined the line the
human line the you know of who is human
who is not human does any is any ethnic
group faces any challenges or questions
like what the Negro faced in the past
new to these scientific research I don't
think so I mean I think there's there's
absolutely no credible genetic research
which suggests that racial distinctions
among ostensible human beings put them
into a separate species and as regards
disease whether it's schizophrenia or
sickle cell disease
there's no sort of categorization of a
specific sort of racial sort of
identification those is purely based on
the genetic principles of whether you
carry a particular disease allele or
have suffered a mutation which has
caused it but the the racial politics
has been completely appropriately and
finally completely deleted from credible
scientific investigation so that's
something we can we can sort of lament
what may have gone before but we can
take some consolation in the fact that
that's you know yes that's right I mean
that the human species is extremely
uniform and the separation into
different races is is a very very minor
separation we're very very close next
question
good evening touching back to or there's
been a string a recent string of
conversations in my own life where
there's been an underlying question and
then looking around for different
opinions I've looked in you know
Christopher Hitchens and Sam Harris's
work and even your own work in The God
Delusion the questions my question is
can any good or a great good come from
religion good as in beneficial to
humanity enough to keep there in our
society or should we do away with it I
don't think any good can come of it but
I don't think we should do away with it
in the sort of dictatorial sense I would
like to think what it would simply
wither away but I fear that may take
rather a long time what do you mean by
in the first sense of good that no good
can come of it I simply can't think of
any of any good that comes with it as in
I'm told by our stage manager we only
have time for one more question two more
questions I don't want I don't want two
more questions okay
make them brief please please yeah hello
mr. Richard Dawkins I'm a big fan
I've always wondered the question about
intelligence and well the singularity of
intelligence and I wanted to ask you in
particular about is there any room in
evolution for a pinnacle of intelligence
or a singularity of intelligence in a
species or the human race
what was the word before singularity a
pinnacle pinnacle climax I don't know
what's the word like that would mean I
can kind of see what a singularity might
mean it might mean a sudden abrupt
change a sudden change if you want the
word I could like change it to
perfection perfect yeah well I mean I
did okay let's stick with with
singularity which which would which
would sort of mean a sudden abrupt
change I don't know that I mean I I
think it's arguable that the the origin
of language was a singularity it
we don't nobody knows how language
evolved nobody knows whether it would
happen gradually like virtually all
other major evolutionary changes or
whether there was a major singularity a
sudden a sudden change so that would
probably be the best guess I could think
of would mediate would be the origin of
language I think the idea of a pinnacle
or a perfection would be difficult
because there's so many different forms
of intelligence also yes sir
the last question I'm sorry we can't
take any more just because of the time
constraints okay I look the Dawkins on
the students and I have a question about
role of religion establishing
communities because I grew up in Miami
Beach and there are all half a million
Jews here and I noticed something that
they always seem to be very well connect
with each other you
the friends I have there secular but do
you think that religion has a role in
establishing communities or are there
better ways to establish community
because they seem to be people around me
are very well connected with each other
and I kind of wish there was way from me
yes I think that's right and that I mean
what's good about it is of course the
idea of community and fellowship and
friendship and that's what we should be
working towards you certainly don't need
religion to do that you could you can
set up community and fellowship and the
that that's what we ought to be to be
doing rather than tying it to
supernatural superstition
[Applause]
[Music]
but the second that concludes our first
day of live coverage from the Miami Book
Fair
we are back tomorrow at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern for more author talks and your
calls with the likes of Randall Kennedy
and David Rothkopf today's entire
schedule will re-air tonight at midnight
Eastern right to the right of the
elevate